the president is set to roll out his
strategy to get more coveted shots in
the arms of americans
just as the delta variant spreads and
cases are on the rise
fox can now confirm the cdc will release
tomorrow the data that led to its recent
reversal on masts
all this as critics say democrats have
only themselves to blame for vaccine
hesitancy
because of comments like this
we're not changing the science you know
what changed chris the virus
changed and the science evolved
with the changing virus that's under
consideration right now but if you're
not vaccinated you're not nearly as
smart as i thought you were
it's like drunk drivers you don't have
the right to go out and drink and drive
and put everybody else at risk including
your own life at risk
ben shapiro welcome back to the show
your thoughts on this
i mean the amount of bad data that has
been purveyed by our supposed public
health experts is astonishing if you
want to talk about the people who have
actually undermined confidence in our
institutions it's the leaders of these
institutions
themselves it's cdc director rashel
welinski going on tv yesterday and
suggesting
that perhaps one out of every ten people
who's vaccinated is going to get a
breakthrough case the actual stats from
the cdc suggest that the actual number
is more like one in every one thousand
it's people like dr fauci suggesting
that the cdc has not flip-flopped
unmasking with regard to vaccination and
then admitting to the washington post
that he doesn't have
actual hard data to back his supposition
that higher viral load
among the vaccinated then suppose is
going to lead to higher levels of viral
transmission
these people have been fibbing to us all
along they think that they can control
us
and not give us the data if you want to
at least make a recommendation on policy
you cannot lie about the data or provide
us no data and then expect us to follow
your
all-knowing guidance and kennedy so it's
our understanding tomorrow we can look
forward to that data being released
but how will that impact americans
continuing confusion to ben's point
and will that reassure anyone frankly no
because
if the cdc and dr fauci and
everyone from the white house is telling
you that you have to wear masks and that
there's
imminent danger from the variants
then people who aren't vaccinated are
not going to get vaccinated there's
nothing they're going to say which is
either clarifying
or convincing and that's the ultimate
problem here because they have forgotten
what they're trying to do are they
trying to
scare people or are they trying to get
people vaccinated
because at this point neither one is
working and all they have done
with the back and forth and the
confusion is
create massive distrust and it's it's
really
hard uh to get a clear picture of what's
going on
with the virus and even though the virus
is changing
that's what viruses do that doesn't mean
that it's getting more deadly and they
they have to be honest about that
and morgan ben also brought up sort of a
power grab essentially by the democrats
let's play a saw a short video of what
senator ted cruz had to say about that
watch it's pure politics
you know what yesterday vaccines work
today they still work but as a political
matter
the democrats decided they want to
control your lives my view is real
simple
we shouldn't have federal government
mandates
on covid morgan
yeah i agree with that and the wall
street journal in their editorial i
think laid it out perfectly
this morning obviously against federal
mandates but talking about the fact that
private employers
do have a right to make those decisions
and demand certain things of of their
workforce so i think it's
really nuanced but what is really
important this whole discussion
is we took all of last year to
politicize
covid and what should have happened to
somebody who was on uh
in the trump administration i
volunteered over the summer
uh working on operation warp speed and
on the covet effort
i've got to tell you every senior person
that i know in the administration
kaylee has talked about that received
the vaccine because we were all a part
of operation warp speed
and we knew that president trump and his
team made heroic
efforts to get this vaccine out but what
has happened is that the democrats use
most of 2020 to politicize kovid to
politicize the vaccine
in order to uh to sow seeds of distrust
and now you have a now you have 2021
where people are not believing each side
and where president biden is spending
more time going on and talking about
voting rights and infrastructure
legislation as opposed to saying you
know what
president trump did something right with
operation warp speed now let's all come
together
and take this vaccine and do what we can
do
to to end this pandemic but instead they
just continue to talk down to people who
haven't gotten the vaccine
and they continue to politicize this
process to the detriment of the american
people
right and julie morgan mentions talking
down to those american people i mean we
had speaker pelosi talking down to her
colleague
kevin mccarthy when she said quote he's
such a for questioning the science
behind returning to the mass
restrictions on capitol hill
and don't worry that the regulations
have been released and you can only be
arrested by capitol police if you fail
to comply
not if you just don't wear a mask in the
first place i mean don't those guys have
anything
have anything better to do at all i'm
just so sick of hearing democrats
talking on both sides of their mouths
and as far as nancy pelosi is concerned
don't bring up follow the science if
you're not yourself actually preaching
you know and following what you preach
if you want to follow the science then
follow the facts the facts are this
that 150 million people have been
vaccinated there have been only 65 000
breakout cases breakthrough cases
those of us who have been vaccinated
that got the delta variant or
the original covid 19. that means that
only 0.04 percent of americans are
actually getting it now no vaccine is
100 but if you want to follow the
science here's the science vaccines work
and so if you have been vaccinated you
should not be put under these mass
mandates as they said from the very
beginning that if you've got a vaccine
you don't need to wear a mask so once
again the democrats are now
doing a 180 and making zero sense when
it comes to
making these mandates necessary for
those of us who went ahead and got the
second shot
and emily if i could just point out
something that i think is very important
they need better marketing here
and julie's absolutely right they need
to be screaming from the mountaintops
and it doesn't even matter if they give
the former president credit they need to
be saying the vaccines work the vaccines
are safe
the vaccines are the best in the world
and there was one study that came out
recently that said the pfizer vaccine
has actually been increasing women's cup
sizes
and and that is a phenomenal piece of
marketing that i think all americans
could get behind i'm so glad i didn't
get pfizer i don't need any more help
why isn't that on the front pages uh so
ben i come to you for a bit of
prediction here to kennedy's point
do you see any type of change in in the
marketing moving forward do you see any
type of
cognizant shift by the democrat party as
we enter into 2022 acknowledging
the hideous impact that their mixed
messaging has had on the american people
and likely
the permanent damage it's done on their
already fractured party do you see them
acknowledging that at all and making
corrections
not at all because for them to
acknowledge that they've botched the
public health message would be to
take the blame for what they perceive to
be republican failures and for what they
want to portray
as republican failures and again the big
problem here
right now is that if you want to
incentivize people to get the vaccine
what you should be saying
is that the vaccinated have no
responsibility to prevent you from
getting the disease you have a
responsibility
to prevent you from getting a disease
and that responsibility lies in going
and getting the vaccine they're not
going to do this because there is no
logical endpoint this all started
with flattening the curve so we didn't
overwhelm the hospital system we avoided
it then it was wait until the vaccine
was available it's available then it was
wait until everybody's had a chance to
get the vaccine
everybody's had a chance to get the
vaccine so what exactly is the endpoint
there is no endpoint
hi when i'm brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now